the credit the wages they were so  [ __ ] cool that like they bare this  guy i just heard a guy get up and i was  like oh [ __ ] this guy's gonna we're  going back and forth he gets up and i  hear him go  and i was like [ __ ]  nails me right here all these sassy  hispanic waitresses uh barricade the  stage for me  and i'm just i just watched chris murphy  walking me out whoa yeah he was like  he's waiting for you so i'm gonna walk  you out he's a great guy great guy first  threesome i ever had was the only time i  got spat i got spat on in philly and  then i had a threesome after the show it  was a very different spitting story yeah  these two girls were like  [ __ ] that guy come on let's go drink and  we went out drinking and like we had a  threesome and then i spit on them and my  cousin yeah remember my cousin goes did  you leave with those two chicks i go  yeah and he goes  i gotta start getting spit on  yeah it's not a bad night